and yes hello and welcome to CD playing
veteranos from Russia so we have the
Roxy bind the transposition tea place
them good meets a system like here
Hansen's choice between yeah those
setups with a 6 and with a 5 trip to d7
okay so see trying to play the size
maybe I'm still covering it and also
okay so this is a very well known
structure where the bishop is usually on
e6 here yeah I am wonder if I can
somehow use this in a very direct idea
would be c5 in this position if he takes
it as e five winning material let's try
if I get to take on the six that he has
to check with the pawn that is
structurally very desirable it sound
probably a good defense probably on the
capture he wants to move the bishop and
my development is a development sucks so
I basically have to take there's no no
choice really so I cannot take on it
several as my queen hangs so
hmm concave a little capture I would
have you high so if we if we trade like
if i move the night I mean and you
cannot take with the rook se5 would wing
the exchange okay very tough ok so we
captured no antique with this and after
rook takes i have e five roped it to
keeney to Bishop 86 f 4 so this is what
he has to do at the end now I would like
to answer d 5 with e5 that's really what
i would want to do Bishop g5 is
interesting in that regard and just
different and then it was also good am
okay look I do it differently a speed up
in absolutely preparing 94 here on d5 I
go each five was the what's the plan
our youth development is pretty good i
mean ii can never be worse en
distillation rather than the opposite
okay some night f4 Bishop h6 I have
Bishop d2 that's not throwing me all
that much the idea of night air force to
control with d5 so trying to check on f6
and then put school identify via that
that I will gladly do 97
can also take here immediately I would
have had 59 system one I don't have a
good square i'm running okay
oh let's say move i didn't have on the
raid idol that's bad but I didn't think
of this 96 now is a threat I just need a
bit of coordination than my position is
totally okay fine morning I just don't
know if I get it is the thing so if i go
to d3 i probably have to do this first
push the bishop away
yeah look see what I think is ok you can
get h four words i'm getting the bee
pollen back and at the end I've got the
outside a pawn okay I can also grab f5
okay then I'm not sure about it was good
or not because now the King gets
extremely active
okay I should be a bit quickly here yeah
can I prevent him no probably not check
[Music]
[Music]
check check check check check mate I was
close we it was really really close ok I
already rate of game I wonder about some
things around the opening this a six
Bishop d7 Queen 85 is really really
uncommon really uncommon combination I
couldn't really yeah it was what i did
was certainly no refutation it was a
tribe but probably i'm not really
working so the thing is if he takes it
five is easily understandable i'm
winning a piece even though it is kind
of yeah what the engine says is true
wait if he gives amazing okay it's not
nothing that somebody does voluntarily
but now black has two pawns my king is
in the middle it's pretty not enough but
still on not an automatic win this was
however i think a good a good decision
what he did yeah now you can argue night
a force maybe the quicker way of doing
it as I'm not obstructing my bishop this
might be questioned but my development
is really not good the engine wants to
do this
actually I thought I have to be five but
ok so this does work I had a computer
just place the exchange down whoo yeah
yeah that's it that's very good
compensation for black you threatening
bishop age six now and my five phone is
hanging and the computer the engine
wants to give it to give stuff back
already yeah is this thing okay and
equal yeah that's certainly true now i'm
inside advantage for black actually is
more active i think the likelihood of
equality is relatively high but or the
draw so yeah this was good now i had the
suspicion that I'm just to lose here
yeah I thought about something like this
the engine is run roughly equal but ok
did this not have form ok 8 so I took it
95 and here you can certainly certainly
argue about move orders and everything
up like this which wasn't good yeah this
is the alternative and now look to a
once and clean room interesting I mean
this would be completely ok if i can
trade of all looks but i won't manage ok
that's a tough one so this is this we
had and i have form and then keygen
interesting f1 instead of h for this
this makes a lot of sense yeah i can do
the same thing essentially without
hanging the age for now
that's a bit stupid yeah the resulting
ending either must be good for wider I'm
simply close to the action and the a
pawn will be strong King III is stronger
okay they are night before maybe
strongly instead of grabbing F porn porn
doesn't seem so essential it okay yes 30
seconds you have to have to be quick yet
here i think my pawns are just quicker
no I've screw it up in some way because
I mean we had a draw 95 so I can now
have a big big chick okay Jeff I am well
not the quick note no time ok so here I
will with Queen g8 I of course him of
course and that's it a stupid one today
okay but okay I have an f 9 seconds this
is really initiate some iight structure
okay chest okay
check me in my primos you can do it yeah
tough game thanks for watching